crazy
cnc machining crazy
[Music]
titans of cnc and welcome to the
bombastic
show this is episode two out of
six episodes that are gonna play out
through the next couple days
and uh let me tell you we've had some
drama we've had some excitement
and uh but at the end of the day we're
cutting chips and we're solving problems
we're making it happen and we're
bringing
deals deals deals and uh let's actually
take a look in this machine and i'll
talk to my son tyson real quick
nice nice nice nice a little bit a
little bit of drama
earlier with that two-inch drill if you
guys didn't see it go to episode one
and we took this massive drill
i'm gonna grab this thing like
we're not playing we're not playing
right i told him this should be a hood
ornament on his car right here i'll
let my son hold this bad boy but uh
took this drill and popped it right
through 140
pound piece of stainless straight
through
over a foot deep out the other side
and uh we ran into a little complication
but at the end of the day
you know it it was live right it was
live so
it was a little bit of uh oh man
but at the end of the day we're
machinists
kept our cool went to something else
solved that problem restarted it
boom right through success and it was
amazing
great job brother you you like you
killed it i
you you like just kept that cool and
made it all happen i'm very proud of you
thank you a little bit a little bit of
stress but no problem right it's a way
to
open the show everything about it it's a
live
shot doing big things right if you're
doing boom bastic
you can't do small things we got to go
and test the limits of
everything and you can see that's
exactly what we were doing
so i'm going to put this back down
and uh now we're on the big
smx 3100 doing some five
axis work cutting some fins into this
amazing part and uh what is that is that
the te yeah harvey one t awesome so
that's the harvey one
t e one right through there big cut so
you can see
how it's changing angles i mean just the
beauty of this machine right there
using all the axis just moving
getting after it big cuts
so good uh if you guys don't know i just
want to say
hey we actually have tooling gift cards
at store.titansofcnc.com
and that is uh tooling cards for
whatever tools you want from canon metal
you get the cards 50
off and it is absolutely amazing and uh
to talk
more about the deals i'm going to bring
in our
our special guests and my co-host
mr dave burgundy what's up
hi how are you it's great to be back i'm
great man
that's great amazing how was that how
was that drill that drill
that drill is incredible it's i don't
know if you saw it but that's going to
put a dent in uh
whatever whatever that's going to be
right there some kind of part i believe
metal
absolutely boom awesome
awesome so we'll maybe give away some
stuff yes absolutely
awesome i'm gonna step back and let dave
make it happen i appreciate that
now you know last time i was here i
promised
a giveaway did i not and you should know
by now as america's
second favorite news man i'm coming for
you dan rather
that i always keep my promise and if i
told you i'm going to give you something
i will by god give it to you
i promise all right so we're all about
solving problems here at titans of cnc
and if the problem that you have is
you've never won anything
then i'm about to solve that problem for
you
now if your name is bill stanwick you
just won from our last giveaway and what
did you win
you won all of this a mega prize pack
from all of our partners
the heimer amazing picnic set
so after you finish cutting chips you
can go eat some chips
you can drink some wine this would
murder somebody but don't use
it for that use it to open a bottle of
wine trust me on that
i won't make that mistake twice okay so
bill stanwick congratulations you're a
winner
of this epic prize pack and stay tuned
because we will be giving away more
follow me over here won't you
now if you want to win even more prizes
all you have to do to win something in
the range of this
is share the feed so the feed that we
have right now that you're watching that
i'm on and my face is in your face
on your internet device hit the share
button and we're going to find you
through the magic of the internet and
you might win a prize like this
the other thing we're giving away
through this through this episode
these titan academy toolkits one tool
kit will go this episode so
there is a building block series for the
mill and there's a rocket series for the
lathe
and whichever flavor you prefer someone
will win that and all you have to do to
enter this giveaway
is tag a friend and comment i want that
kenmetal toolkit
so what do you have to do say it with me
tag a friend comment i want that kind of
no two kit
and you might be a winner now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna go back over to
titan
because they are going to continue to
create this
masterpiece of a part out of some kind
of metal
that i do not know the name of using
massive tools
titan
oh man oh man thank you mr dave burgundy
the man the myth the legend the money
man and he's going to be
back later in the episode with crazy
crazy deals so over here
we're showing you guys how to machine in
a way that allows you to compete in this
industry
and make money for your families and
dave is showing you how to spend
less of that money because of the crazy
deals that our
industry partners give and uh nice
it's looking pretty awesome right yeah
super cool
so uh we're just going to go and we're
going to machine
all those fins away and uh just keep
moving right forward
yep roughing them all out right now with
the tv
no no you're not a smooth sailing right
yeah smooth sailing now you got the te
just going no problems awesome awesome
you know before our next guest i just
want to say
um a lot of people ask say titan how can
we actually help you guys we love that
you give a free education to our
industry love
everything that you're doing for the
industry and you guys know
we're doing the crazy deals we don't
take a cut from these deals
because we want you guys to get all of
the deals all right so
it's all about you guys but if you want
to help us please
go down and actually grab this video
right here and
share it with as many people as you can
and um pass out the words so that other
shops
other people can get inspired to
actually start machining
and get the deals and uh with that i'm
going to invite
my good buddy mr chris wood right back
on here
ah and we're back ellison baby and we're
back
boom how are you good man good good good
hey so uh
yeah we had some uh some nice drama but
now we're just smooth sailing we're
doing some
nice five axis work inside this machine
right here this is nine axis machine we
are it's nice it's very nice and we we
love a bit of drama
we love a bit of hollywood we love it
right because we solved that problem we
did so i wouldn't love it if we didn't
solve it
terrible i bet everybody was like scared
it was like
everybody at home was like oh what are
they gonna do you know what i mean it is
cool under pressure solve that problem
because in life you hit
roadblocks and you gotta get run away
from them nope
can't turn that camera off it is live
indeed
indeed so when we were talking earlier
we talked about the machine
we talked about the nine axis and what
it can do
and but i think a lot of people they
wonder like
why why why would i want to buy this
machine
i could go buy a three axis mill i could
buy a two axis lathe
for less money why why would i go out
why would i buy this machine and
more drama nice nice
look at that look at that cut love it so
what again
why would we buy this machine and it all
comes down and you talked about it it's
making more money how can we become more
efficient with our process
and right now in in the shops out there
your biggest asset
is your labor yeah but also your biggest
challenge to find good guys
is also labor so the good guys that you
have in the shop guys or girls in the
shop that you have running the machines
you want them to maximize their time and
be as efficient and productive and as
value-added as possible
by combining operations you can
you can remove all of that setup or that
non-value add
and put it all into the machine so that
when your spindle is cutting you're
making money
absolutely and and what do i mean by
that so for example if you've got a
lathe and you're going to make this part
on the lathe right you've got to come in
you've got to turn it we're going to
drill it
maybe we use some live tools for it but
let's say you're a job shop and the next
day you have a different part to make
and then you're like oh man i need
another one of those angled live tool
holders
well that's another four or five grand
six round whatever i'm going to spend on
that
and then you've got another part and you
need two more of those language live
tool holders
and then you run out of turret positions
and then you've got to tear down your
whole setup
but a machine like this one the multi
process in that upper head
because you've got a tool changer all
you're changing out if you want to go
from a half inch drill
to a 3 8 drill to a 5 16 whatever you
want to do
all your j doing is doing a tool change
yeah same thing with your turning tools
as well you can keep dedicated or
big monster tools or big drills keep
those dedicated down the bottom
but we could use that tool changer in
combination with that true milling head
which is going to allow you as a shop
owner to basically save
money and you're going to make more
parts and make more money and become
more efficient and you're going to be
able to feed your families better and go
on cool vacations and everything else
that goes along with it
and you know that you you ran a shop you
owned a shop you know that challenge of
setup and every time you move apart from
one machine to another you may scrap
it but it all comes down to the parts
and that's why i mean this machine this
this platform
is so well designed for job shop type
environments where you've got a hey you
know one day you get a po for this part
next day you've got to change it over
you've got to make something else you
need to be up and running as quick as
possible
that's where this type of platform is
really going to take advantage and they
go all the way down
real small like eight inch trucks and
they go big
all the way up to five meter bed lengths
and bigger with steady rest and more
powerful spindles
so it all comes down to the part that's
kind of my thoughts on
why this is a great tool absolutely
absolutely i mean uh
everything you just said i agree with
and uh
you got to get the machines working by
themselves producing a part in one
operation
and i'll also add like when you uh when
you're opting things out
inspection is much more difficult you
have a better chance to actually scrap
those parts and stuff but when you do
everything in the same
same setup it just works
yeah and that's that setup talking about
that chuck there
that is your work holding yeah doesn't
matter if you had a square piece of
block
an octagon a triangle round
your work holding is in the machine so
that part of that
that's taken care of right whereas on a
mill you'd have to go and design
some fixture for it but you just use the
chuck boom
everything all of it nine axis works
nine axis making it happen
indeed how is when you look at the
industry
as a whole um how is it like
not that a lot of people are going for
those five axis right now and the nine
axis and um
all these mill turns and stuff is their
understanding they they have to
it's honest it's the only way you're
going to compete because
hypothetically if you tighten owner own
a job shop
and you've got a whole shop full of
these and somebody down the road is
making it on
two axis lathes and three axis mills and
having to move it around the shop and
pay all that additional
resource and wasted time you're
ultimately going to be more profitable
you can probably quote the job for less
but make a higher margin on your on your
sales
and be a hell of a lot more efficient
with it as well yeah
and and that's that's the trend and the
these sort of high technology machines
with the
the multi-process miltons the five axis
machines that we're going to see
tomorrow and thursday
that's that's the direction of the
future and i think if you're really
going to be a key player even
if you're all the way down a little shop
starting up all the way up to the big
guys
you've got to look at taking on this
technology and embracing it and running
with it
because it's the future awesome you guys
are
you guys got some crazy deals on these
machines right now say what is this
machine about
25 off i think up to 25 percent on
certain models and machines
i think the mill turns are right in that
you know
it's 30 off on the education titan
package yep
i believe the mill turns are 25
off and then select other machines
are 20 20 off those and while everybody
else is raising prices you guys are
bringing the crazy discounts we are we
just
we we want american manufacturers global
manufacturers we're obviously in america
right now
we want to help them succeed when
compete
make money support their families i
think the website's what
titans for doosan.com i think so check
that one out
get on there we'll get you some
information on pricing but it's uh
yeah phenomenal machine great technology
and ultimately reach it reach out to
doosan reach out to the distributors
ellison or any the other uh distributors
and see how we can help you out we can
look at your parts help pick the right
platform for the machine
and ultimately try and make you
successful oh
love it brother thanks a lot mate
appreciate it thank you very much for
being here
and uh when it comes to the deals
titansofcnc.com
promo you can check out all the deals
right there and again
mr dave burgundy will be back to
actually show you guys how to actually
make some
money and save money and all of that all
right
so uh i'm gonna actually uh come in and
then we are gonna bring in
aaron grill from lns
right now and we're going to make
something happen all right
aaron l s how's it going man good man
good to see you
problem solver extraordinaire making it
happen
boom yeah so one thing that's kind of
overlooked
with uh buying this big expensive
machine tool is
a critical piece is the miss collection
you're overlooking um
protecting your most valuable asset
which is your employee
absolutely so and doosan has done a
doosan has done a good job with uh
having
a nice location for the inlet that way
you're pulling the mist away
from the operator and making sure that
the cabin's clear and
another benefit of miss collection would
be keeping your
shop floor clean and your equipment
clean absolutely you know one thing
mythical especially
with covered with all of the different
things and stuff
and we film so miss collecting is
huge one of the things that i love about
lns and the miss
collectors is that it's so
quiet right a lot of these people they
actually a lot of companies they put it
right on top of the machine
and they're loud like you know
and uh these guys they actually plumb it
and
i actually you also do the high pressure
coolant
so it'll be in the back of the machine
and then uh
they just piggyback on top of it so we
have the mist collector on the high
pressure coolant
or on the you know where wherever it
makes sense
you guys even have your own special
stands we've got stands
a few that are on tip conveyors so lots
of
mounting options awesome and then uh you
guys have some deals too
we do have some deals so buy one miss
collector and get the second one
50 off awesome and then we also are
including a free premium accessory kit
with each miss collector purchase and
this premium accessory kit just kind of
helps
uh enhance the performance of the miss
collector and then makes it easier for
installation
uh and we're also giving away a free
spray cabin one of our new products that
we just released
so uh sign up for that and uh we're
gonna draw a lucky winner next week whoo
it's exciting that spray cabinet i'm
excited about that so it just you're
basically blowing off the parts
it just sucks the water right in there
yep
so like when you when you're machining
parts and typically you take it out of
the out of the
out of the vise you're spraying off the
mist and it's going all over the floor
well we have a spray cabin that you can
blow off the the mist
into the spray cabin itself and then
that way keeps the floor
clean and it protects your operators
from breathing in those harmful fumes
cool man cool so um how long you been
with l s
uh coming up on four years now four
years yep awesome awesome
and uh i see a lot of shops you know
they got a lot of different machines so
you don't actually have to get a miss
collector with the machine when you
purchase it
you can you guys can actually build it
and give it to for pretty much any
machine
yep right yeah they can go on it right
in yep you can go on any machine
they can go on during the purchase or
five years after the purchase
we can run them via m code lots of
different options lots
lots of flexibility with the
installation
awesome awesome thank you brother take
care super good man
and i'm gonna call back in mr dave
burgundy
uh what's up dave how are you how are
you man
we're gonna do some mastercam program
we're gonna do some machining we're
gonna do some different things but i
thought you know what
how about we remind them of some of the
deals deals deals crazy deal
that is a terrific idea boom all right
all right
so deals deals
what is the what is the last part deals
deals
it'll come to me don't worry let's get
to the deals the titans of cnc academy
store at store.titansofcnc.com
has fifty percent off those kenmetal
tooling gift cards
in denominations of one thousand twenty
five hundred and five thousand dollars
now this is a usa only promo so go and
get those
because there is a limited quantity in
there fifty percent off which i'm told
is quite a bit of money
twenty percent off all shirts posters
and everything else
and that deal is worldwide when you use
code boom bastic
at store.titansofcnc.com
now this giant beautiful bluish
i'm going to call it lavender-esque
machine behind me it's a thing of beauty
and i'd love to drive one of these to
work every day wouldn't you
i know i would so these beautiful
machines now
doosan is doing 20 off some of the
newest five axis machines
25 percent off some of select mill turn
and y-axis turning centers
and up to 30 percent off the titans of
cnc
training package so once they do that
you are going to save so much money on
the mill
the lathe and all of that now that is
u.s only
and in america so make sure you go to
titansfordusons.com
and get all of the full details there
one of the other things doosan is doing
is they are giving away a free gerstner
now we saw that earlier and it might be
up on screen right now if my graphics
guys are doing their job like they're
supposed to
so look at that beautiful beautiful
chest you can put anything in there
little bits of hair
fingernails tools even i mean that's
what i hear
so they're giving that away at
titansforduson.com
solidworks is coming up and i believe
we're going to see that immaculate
screen in action again where they're
touching it and doing the things with
their fingers i'm very intrigued by that
that is the 3d lean system and right now
it's just 150 for 90 days
and that's over a 500 savings they're
also doing a free upgrade when you buy
solidworks today
mastercam who we'll hear from in a
little bit is also doing 20
off of multi-axis they have their 160
dollar
mastercam education suite that includes
over 100 free
posts to use in the tech exchange now
you can find
information about all these deals at
titansofcnc.com
promo metal's end mill deal is still
going on as well so these are some of
our favorite tools the core five the
harvey
iii the harvey one te and the harvey one
te
ball nose those are starting at 22
now that's enough where you can go i can
afford both a pizza
and an end mill and what world can you
say that in other than this one right
here
they're also doing 70 off of tooling
gift cards when you purchase a doosan
during the show
and that's pretty incredible kenneth
metal is also doing a free giveaway so
all you have to do to enter these is go
to kmt dot
co slash boom bastic and you could win
an amazing
gift card values i can't tell you yet
but it's in the thousands
make sure you go to kmt dot co slash
boombastic for that
and shunk shunk our amazing workholding
partner
they're doing 20 off of the vero s
packages
and buy one get one free on all of the
impact series claw jaws
you don't want to miss out on that
because again they're going to cradle
that material
like a like a ripened banana
gentle you don't want to smash that
banana
have you ever had a banana that good
where you go
i just want this banana i don't want to
crush it
chunk will help you with that or metal
if you decide to put metal in a shrunk
vise that's fine too
but really they're built for bananas you
can take that to the bank
all right other deals blaser swiss lube
has 20 percent off of their coolings and
cutting oils
for new five-axis customers for their
initial fills
and they're doing 20 off of their
cleaners and accessories
now are you ready to come back and chat
about some more metal cutting and that
kind of stuff
excellent thank you money money money
money money
all right money man here we go mr dave
bergen day
so uh today so right now tyson is
actually
running the tools getting everything all
dialed in and then we're gonna keep
machining
and we're going to actually go over the
master cam programming
but in a minute i just want to go ahead
and send it over to inspection
we have some crazy deals plus we're
going to show you some
high level cmm techniques and
and just different inspection techniques
all right so
uh before you go plea before i put you
over the inspection
uh go ahead and share this video like
comment
and uh thank you guys so much for tuning
in so i'm gonna send you
over to inspection right now
with travis and the mitutoyo team then
we'll come back over here
and we'll go over some mastercam
programming and we'll continue
machining the part all right boom
hello everybody welcome to the
inspection lab here at titans of cnc in
flower mound texas
we're excited to have you guys this is
our brand new inspection lab
uh i am travis i am here with jared
kangelo talking about
king lao how you doing my friend doing
good how are you good good hey so we're
excited like i say to have you guys here
we know you've been doing some
multi-access work out there on the smx
nine axes very impressive we want to
show you kind of something in a similar
vein
not quite nine axes right but we do have
a new building a new lab
and behind me here we have a krista apex
with a ph
25 axis head so a lot of things to
cover on this machine we're only going
to cover a couple so we're going to jump
right into it so
jarrod yes 5x's head right now uh if
you've ran other cmm machines i've ran
other cmms
they can still move in five axes right
that's correct yeah so what
distinguishes this head right here
from one of those other five-axis heads
so with the other this
ph 20 here we can move it all
simultaneously simultaneously all five
axes
compared with the other cmm's where the
probe head would move in two axes
yeah and then the machine then would
come in and start measuring the part
from there
so from kind of like a from a machinist
standpoint that would be like a three
plus two kind of programming correct
exactly
okay so we're gonna have full
simultaneous five axis movement
right i think we have a demonstration of
that maybe yep
all right so we're going to go ahead and
i think we're going to just about
hold on here we go we're going to come
up and there she is she's going to make
a nice little rotation yeah a nice
little
ballerina toilet got a little nutcracker
actually going on right so
exactly okay so nice fast speed we're
establishing our base plane there
we're doing a cnc alignment here so that
it knows where the parts at
yeah so that can start measuring around
there's another full five axis move
right there
very impressive so with the ph 20 head
right we
have it's uh capable efficient movements
right so we have the full simultaneous
five axis movement
we also have what uh infinite uh angle
yes different angles
tell us a little bit about that yeah it
basically rotates uh less than an angle
and getting into hard places that we
couldn't do in the older program
so less than a degree yeah less integral
yes okay
so i know like on some of the older
cmm's if you guys remember you got the
little boxes with the little little
check marks you got to make exactly
seven and a half degrees 15 degrees 22.5
degrees that's right those are the
degrees that you're
locked into and you can't check anything
really efficiently if it's not on that
angle
yeah exactly like we have 40 holes here
at varying angles 90 degrees separation
with the old program you couldn't get
all those holes without running at least
two or three times the program
together so helps us really you know be
be a more efficient programmer exactly
gotcha so now one of the things with
that right we have
full five axis head movement right we
got infinite angles or
less than a less than a degree right
approaching infinite right you know um
so
so that helps us from my understanding
right what does that give us in a
benefit to respect to
this space right here that we're
checking parts that allows us to
optimize the space of the
cmm getting around the part uh a lot
more smoothly compared to with the old
cmm where it comes out and then goes
back in well and one thing they were
talking about there at the smx that i
like they talk about you know not having
to break down setups right having the
ability
to you know kind of multitask so with
this we might be able to maybe sneak
another part in there or something like
that
multiple setups we'd be able to you see
how long the space is on the cmm so
we're able to run another part
in the back back there maybe even side
by side given enough
space for the probe yeah oh there's a
nice little five axis move for the end
all right so we have uh one more part
show off the uh dance moves of our head
here right
okay all right so some of you guys you
guys might recognize this part right
here
this is our titanium king all right xl
and actually if you go to the academy we
actually have a video with tyson
showing you guys how to machine this
part right here now we're going to do a
little inspection on it that's right
thank you very much
all right and right now it's just
switching uh
probe trees so that allows for a longer
stylus to get into some of these tricky
angles here yeah and so i like that i
don't know if you guys can see but we
have a six station
uh probe changer right here pro rack has
six six different modules there
we have a standard force medium force a
em-1 an em2
uh light force and a six-way so that's
yeah so definitely a lot of options to
tackle the different nuances that you
might run into
in an inspection environment that's
right very nice very nice uh so you're
ready yes
all right let's do it let's go
all right i've seen that several times
and it still gives me a little bit of a
heart taxing to
rush towards that program what is our so
we have rapid speed on this right
roughly
roughly about 600 millimeters gotcha on
there
and so again another little alignment
yep little nice rotation right here
now this is this is what i kind of like
about this we have we're not using
um really uh the machine room we're
using head touch right yes
tell us a little bit about that yeah the
head touch there allows for it
just to move the probe head without
moving the big machine uh all of the
mass of it at least
and that allows for a faster inspection
time a faster
calibration time and yeah basically we
don't have to break right we don't have
to accelerate this big machine we have
to slow down this big machine
and you see that with the moves going
around it very close to the part
and then optimizing the movements and
also optimizing
the program timing too so we talk about
optimizing the programming time if we uh
you know if we're if we're good
programmers looking to you guys how what
kind of savings can we
expect to see you can look at about 40
to 65 uh percentage 65
no excuses no excuses all right so here
we go
looks like we're checking a cone that's
right i love that i love that motion
i really do so then we got the head
touch coming around the top again
so i'll see what else uh accuracy and
repeatability
right if we don't it's nice to be
efficient but if we're not accurate
what are we really doing so what are we
talking about accuracy repeatability
you're looking at about 2.2 microns on
there
about a tenth of a thousand inch guys
i'm one too and uh as long
when you increase the length of of
course you lose a little bit of accuracy
but we're still looking about
three mic under three microns here okay
very nice i love that
it does that whole rotation that's that
a axis tilt that you were talking about
right coming underneath
and the max on this instead of the other
pro pad is a 115
degrees and you're able to get nice
movements like that nice little bow at
the end right
like that so that wraps up our small
demonstration of the crista apex we
encourage you to check out mitutoyo and
also our site for more information
we hope to see you guys tomorrow i'll
actually be out on the floor with jason
to bring you some more metrology
solutions from mitsuyo
so we're going to wrap it up but before
we do i think we have a guest
maybe with a little giveaway hey guys
sorry about that i didn't mean to
interrupt no no we're living interrupted
when you're done playing with your
computer robot measuring machine do you
mind if i talk to the people by all
means
thank you so much hey people it's me
again dave burgundy
and i have been looking some for high
and low for something else to give away
because why not let's give more stuff
away can i give these away
i'll give these away all right look at
what we have here it's a beautiful
orange rectangular box
and this could be yours this rectangular
box
that's the thing right it's a okay oh
there's a
there's a little black box inside the
orange box it's really two prizes is
what this is
the orange box and then the black box
inside of it
and there might be now there's something
inside of here too
oh this uh i think it's a barbecue tool
of some sort
now this is a caliper from michitoyo
and you can win one of these and all you
have to do is comment
in the comments below and tag a friend
who is always out of tolerance that
needs one of these and you'll both win
how about that we'll give away two this
time
so all you have to do is say tag a
friend and say this guy
cannot hold tolerance and we're going to
give them one of these
and we're going to give you one of these
so you can both hold your tolerance how
does that sound
all right now is the time to rag on your
friends friends and we're gonna go back
over to titan
in a couple seconds so that he can show
you more amazing machining on that
doosan
awesome thank you mr burgundy
you gotta love that guy he cracks me up
so
we're back at tyson's machine we're
continuing to
machine this incredible part with some
complex
tool paths um when you when you actually
look at it you can't really see it
because we've turned on the
the through spindle high pressure
coolant right there
because we just want to make sure that
all the chips are getting evacuated and
everything's like perfect and uh
it's running nice and smooth right here
at this time i want to bring in
dylan and he is uh from mastercam you
guys know dylan from the last boom
bastic
hey what's going on brother good to be
here good thanks
awesome awesome so
we let's we got everybody out here and
uh let's actually
just have a talk a little bit about
topaz i mean you can have all the
material you can have the
cad but it's all about the cam and
programming those tool paths
so you can actually take advantage of a
9-axis machine
and uh master cam you guys got some
trick trick
tool pads yeah yeah obviously we got a
complex
machine here we got a complex part we
got intimidating tooling
i don't know where that drill went but
it's being passed around like it was
excalibur here
so how are we going to program all that
easily efficiently and safely
so that's going to be done in the
mastercam mill turn module that's what
we're going to use for these kinds of
multi
or multi-tasking machines to
lay out our programs in an easy and
efficient manner
so that combines a lot of different
parts into one module to enable things
like that
we've got a lot of specialized tool
paths for
something like a mill turn machine and
then combined with that we've got the
complexity of the machine
where we've got different streams we've
got a lower turret we've got an upper
head they're all moving around
simultaneously
if you're doing something like actually
bar feeding
you've got the lower turret working on
one half maybe the sub you've got the
upper head working on the other side
so these parts are dancing around each
other and you need full
machine simulation the entire housing
all the axes
all the tooling to understand where
those pieces are
and keep everything nice and safe and
that's all done
in the mill turn module
awesome and uh another cool thing is uh
multi-access is actually you guys got a
good deal going on right now
is that 20 off 20 off multi-axis
so yeah and that's in addition to
the 160 dollar mastercam package
available through titans where you're
actually getting
a full seat of mastercam you can post
from it
and that's everything that's a
multi-axis that's all the specialized
paths
so take a look at that take advantage of
that deal
to get into mastercam and kick cutting
yeah this is a limited time only and uh
mastercam is just
serving our industry so as dylan said
it's 160 dollars you can post with it
you can do multi-access whether you can
do everything and you can go
right onto our academy and you can go
down to mastercam and go through the
building blocks through the rocket
and you can literally teach yourself how
to program
by going through these tutorials so 160
dollars
and no more excuses saying oh they're
not teaching me
i'm not learning if you want to rise up
in this trade
get that software and at home go through
our academy
and take your skills to the highest
level
um i'm gonna actually talk to my son
tyson what's up tys
how are you doing good so i love that
you can you can you
the coolant we got it all nice blasting
those chips out of there
but uh nice rumble right there going on
in the background
and i want to just take a couple of
minutes you guys think you guys can
actually walk
over and actually talk about the tool
path that you're doing and
a little bit about programming this part
and uh just talk right
and give them some skills yeah all right
absolutely so i'm gonna step away and
then uh
boom take it away all right yeah so
let's go over to the computer and we'll
walk down these tool paths
so we start this off pretty simple with
the lathe face and lathe drill
but then right away we get into some of
the more complex
stuff that's only in this mill turn
module so we're starting off with a
pinch turn path pinch turn main and
pinch turn associated here in this case
to remove the bulk of this material off
of the part in the turning operations
before we get into milling
so what is pinch turning that's when
we're coming in
simultaneously with a a turning tool in
the lower turret and a turning tool in
the upper head
and pinching the part and taking
material off on both sides at once
and there's two main reasons to do that
the first reason you might do that
is if you had say a long skinny part
and you were trying to take an
aggressive cut with a single tool you
might get deflection
in that part or in that stock and
with pinch turning you're equalizing
those forces you're coming in from both
sides
and you can actually take a heavier cut
and not worry about that deflection
now obviously that's not a problem with
this part here we've got a lot of stock
here that's not going to deflect
so that's where we come to the second
reason to use it is
we're doing twice as much turning in the
same amount of cycle time
so really awesome path there and then
that
pretty much finishes up our turning on
this part and we can go
right into milling this is a pretty
milling heavy heart
so this is what we had left from the
lathe
paths we had some grooving there in the
center and then we had our
pinch turning that took the bulk of the
material off the front side
and we're going to jump right into the
multi-axis head stuff
that was really easy to make i was able
to just click on the stock model
operation and
tell i told it just calculate the
material
after all of the lathe operations and
generated that
and then yeah and that's so we get a
visual right on the screen here this is
the grain is what's left with stock and
we can directly utilize this
in the following multi-axis paths to cut
down on air time and zero in on
just what we want to cut in between
these blades i actually was using like
after like the milling operations i'd
actually generate the stock model just
so i could see
like how the part would look after like
get a good visual of how the part would
look
yeah and that's an excellent way to
utilize these kinds of stock models
so the first path we've got here is
another kind of specialized path it's a
blade
expert path and that is doing the bulk
of our roughing
around these 10 airfoil blades that are
on this
front diameter of this part and if we
look at this geometry before we even
open up this path
this is pretty complex you know we've
got a radiused floor
we've got these airfoil shapes and
that might wrap around and and cause
issues
for just three axis roughing if we were
doing three plus two positional we
couldn't
get all that material out with a single
positional path
we've got large floor fillets here so
blade expert what this is is this is a
path that is
kind of specialized to automate some of
the programming for these airfoil shapes
so if we walk through the setup of a
blade extra path here
we're feeding it the stock which is
after our lathe operations
and then in cut pattern we've got just a
few choices here there's not much that
we have to fool with on this page
so we could rough we could finish the
blade
the hub or the fill it so this is really
targeting
you know these these blades on hub
shapes impeller shapes anything with
repeating
airfoils around pattern around a part
and then our part definition here super
simple
it's just a single hub floor
and then we're defining the blade
splitters fillets here
which is just 16 surfaces we're giving
it two blades so it understands
the gap in between them and then we're
patterning the rest of the part
around we have 10 segments here
really simplified part definition tool
access control
and this is kind of an automated method
of generation
so what that gives us and i've just
dirtied up the path
so we can't see let's uh let's reopen
this the simulator open
so let's let's jump into
let's jump back into that part because i
want to see the actual blade expert path
here
again we're going for automation here so
this blade extra path
is literally like two three minutes to
set up
and the inputs are very basic
and what you get out of that is a whole
lot of roughing to do this entire part
now if we wanted a little more
efficiency
we could go into a multi-axis pocketing
path
and do more dynamic style motion so
constant cutter engagement here
here we're going really aggressive with
this blade expert we're
full slotting and we're doing this all
in two
depth cuts the entire thing so to
showcase
the other side of this if we wanted more
efficiency a little more
programming time we can jump down
to a multi-axis pocketing path here
and we've targeted a single blade to
rest roth and what we're doing is we're
actually rest
roughing against we made this little pie
slice
stock model so we could kind of zero in
on this programming here
and now we've got more dynamic style
motion where we're efficiently engaging
and coming off that material
in a very controlled manner for the rest
roughing
again with this half inch ball end mill
so
this is a little more set up but it gets
us benefits in terms of
tool motion if we were to try to do this
over the entire
hub it'd be a lot more work than the
blade expert so this is the kind of
trade-off that you have the choice for
i think one of the cool things i also
want to go over here
is for those of you that are looking at
this and you've
been using mastercam lathe and you're
wondering what mill turns all about
you're probably wondering like how do
you set up the planes for this right
this is a lot of
three plus two and multi-access work
that seems like a lot of
uh work to manage these planes and
miltern
has some special tools for that so for
most of this
we're actually deriving the planes to
use for machining
off of the geometry we've selected so
miltern is automatically creating those
planes for us in the background
and aligning the machine correctly to
the work plane so we don't have to worry
about that
if we look in the planes manager a lot
of these are just
auto created planes that occurred as
soon as we generated
the actual tool path with the setup
in the uh the tool path parameters so if
we look at this opti rest and we look at
the setup here
we've got some basic check boxes in
terms of
align with machine maintain spindle
origin to let that tool path know
how it should generate then there's also
things like the uh i have an angled
drill in this part where i just
generated the tool plane just by
clicking on uh
derived from geometry and it angles the
drill properly
based on the hole that's on the part
yeah so we have this
this hole here that's actually breaking
out into an angled face so we couldn't
even easily make a plane
on that face to set it up but because
we're picking the hole as geometry
we already know the plane and miltern is
going to take that and create it in the
background so you don't have to worry
about it
and i wanted one of the things i really
like about mastercam or
just mastercam in general uh
working on this part i was able to
basically split it off into sections so
like i
programmed just you know one face or one
pocket
and then i'd use the transform tool path
function to tell it how many times
around the part
to take that feature and basically it'll
rotate
it'll it'll make it'll copy that program
and rotate it so that
i can do it on multiple sides of the
part so
basically i only have to program one
little section and then
mastercam does the rest of the work so
yeah
as long as my parts symmetrical all the
way around yeah we've got an easy
workload here because everything's
actually patterned around this part
but again if this weren't we could go in
and create those operations and let mill
turn
figure out the planes for us for the
most part
so on this part we actually
we've got it easy in terms of we get
done with the turning and then we go
right into the milling so we don't have
a lot to deal with
with simultaneous upper stream lower
stream choices but we always
have the ability to sync that within
code manager and kind of
basically manage how all these pieces
are moving together in the background
now this part it's a single part single
piece of stock
so when we actually set up this job
that's what we're telling
miltern is our setup here we've got a
single piece of stock that we're going
to pick off
at one point and bring to the sub and
the choices here you know we could
actually select
continuous bar bar stock with an actual
cutoff operation and then a pole
or a feed two separate parts in the main
and the sub and what this is going to do
is kind of automate our programming
down the line and figure that all out
for us
if we did have multiple streams moving
at once we've got
all sorts of different options to handle
this at the tool path level in terms of
turret parks and turret moves and then
also at the sinking level when we
actually post this code
and we have to sync up the operations
so tyson i don't know if you wanted to
actually post a little bit of this and
show us how you would sync your
operations
so what we're doing here when we're
posting code
is we're actually going to post some
intermediate code and then go into code
expert
and this is where we're going to manage
our machine syncs
and determine where we line up those
upper and lower streams
in this machine and then after that
then we've determined exactly what our
program is going to be top to bottom and
we can
launch into the full-blown machine
simulation and check that
the changes we made to the sinks will
still clear on all these components on
the machine itself
and in this case we have a fully modeled
machine we have fully modeled holders
everything is in here so we can with
confidence
go from machine simulation to cycle
start on the machine
that's been a really big help with with
the multi-axis machine
is being able to model the holders and
being able to double check my clearances
because there's a lot of
with the two streams of code that i have
to run there's a lot of clearances and
things i need to watch out
for specifically with some of the b-axis
head motion in this
i see the bx is really leaning over and
the clearances to
chuck jaws and other machine components
get pretty tight
so to be able to see that in machine
simulation first
super important to make sure i'm not
going to hit a jaw or anything when i'm
doing this multi-axis motion
so i have a few of the operations posted
here
and then as dylan mentioned um syncing
them i can
basically time to the i can time the
upper stream
to the lower stream so it only runs at a
certain like when it reaches a certain
point
so uh for this one i can say
after it faces we'll start the pinch
turning operation
and then after the pinch turning
operation we'll go down
and we'll say to start i'll drag it to
the start of the grooving
operation
and then after the grooving operation is
done we'll drag it to the start of the
blade expert operation
and then that's pretty much where all my
milling starts after that
so sink wise this is pretty simple and
if this were any more complex right we
could also save these sinks so they're
associated with those operations we only
do this
once when we post all these operations
and then those states are safe so when
we go to post this again if we make
changes
those things still remain we also have a
lot of options we can toggle with each
individual operation
at this stage in terms of plane rotation
g-codes and such in the background
cooling controls g-codes
things involving the b-axis and then you
also have your retracts here so
we can tell it to go home after the tool
or only home and x if
for some reason we have clearance issues
so this is where we have really granular
control
of the machine motion and the tool path
uh
functionality if we need it in these
drop downs
but otherwise we can leave that alone
and continue on
should i play the yeah good awesome
boom yeah these guys are amazing
amazing software and uh twice the
machine
yeah still just running running running
that rbte
is making it happen and uh boom
killing it super good thank you very
much yeah thanks thanks
awesome all right so let's step over
here
we're gonna keep running the part and as
i stated before uh we actually put the
high pressure coolant to get all the
chips out of there
so you can't see much but we're going to
basically
take this entire video later and we're
going to put it out on youtube
we're going to show the entire process
and then we're going to show you all the
the depths of cuts the axial the radial
we're going to show you
everything speed speed surface foot all
of it
and give you guys that information and
show you the finished part all the
finishing
everything and uh i'm excited because
tomorrow we have an amazing uh
demonstration also my man stuart he's on
the dbf 5000
doing some crazy rough and doing some
crazy finishing
on the titan 40 m
project it's an awesome part just with a
lot of
trick geometry so he's actually going to
come in
to some different ports on the outside
do some full
simultaneous milling and he's going to
do it
fast and efficient it's going to be
awesome all right
so uh right before we end again we're
going to bring deals deals deals
uh remember mastercam 20 off and we got
the 160 dollar
like crazy software that you guys can
buy for 160 dollars
boom and uh mr dave burgundy
i love this guy see i get hyped when he
comes man what's up man hey buddy how's
it going
man more deals what an episode crazy
this has been incredible
the machine keeps running the metal
keeps cutting
and the cutter keeps cutting said metal
that's it man
all right productivity baby boom
beautiful
all right so a couple things we didn't
get to last time now we were in there
with the mitchitoyo boys and
i'd be remiss if i didn't tell you about
the deals they have now that big
robot electric guy that was measuring
things he's fifteen percent off and
that's a crista ex five axis cmm
they're also doing over twelve thousand
off the mystar
555 shop floor cmm and over nine
thousand dollars off that qi
c 2010 d that i am oh so familiar with
the quick image that is over there as
well also up to 35
off their precision tools and
instruments now
you heard from l s earlier and what
they're doing is the buy one get one
half off
on all of the missed collection you need
mystical mist
mist from the ocean mist from the forest
it will collect it all
and it will deposit it into a beautiful
chalice
chalice power that's what i drink from
every morning did you know that the
chalice of power
filled by the lns miss collector that i
got for free
because i work here ha ha but you can
get one buy one get one
50 off on all of the miss collectors and
get a free premium accessory kit
and they're doing the free spray cabin
giveaway
and i'm looking forward to trying to
enter and win that myself
i'd be remiss if i didn't mention once
again the kennen metal tooling gift
cards
50 off on our site at
store.titansofcnc.com
now as we wrap up i have to tell you
about our winners
now there is for the toolkit winner
are we allowed to go over to the
toolkits can we do that is it okay
excellent let's go join me friends
these toolkits one of you has won the
person
whose name is on this card has won a
toolkit and you get to choose
one gentleman by the name of lionel
bogart
just bogarted one of these kits from you
guys he won and you didn't
congratulate him in the comments because
he bogarted these from you
his name is lionel bogart and that's
what he does and you can show him some
love in the comments
now the other giveaway that we have from
mitchutoyo
the cool barbecue tool set what's
it's not a so it's not again it's a
calipers and i keep forgetting that and
they're gonna duck my pay
i'm pretty sure i'm i'm pretty sure i
might not have a job tomorrow but let's
find out
so the winner of that is and now you
guys i got to tell you before i tell you
this name
when i said tell me in the comments who
can't hold tolerance
immediately you threw each other under
the bus
and that's what i like to see i like to
see friends who love friends enough
to talk trash about them so good job on
you millions of comments
bob can't hold tolerance dave can't hold
tolerance jim can't hold tolerance
susie can't hold tolerance now all of
you need to get these mitutoyo calibers
if you can't hold those tolerances but
the person who won
is gabe hozen and i do believe he's
related to
later hozen that's a joke
play on words i'm something of a word
smith that i know if you've noticed
throughout the show but
i tend to turn a phrase gabe hoesen you
won and you tagged your friend jacob
barakov
some kind of pasta lasagna of some sort
berikoff beautiful sauce
mushrooms creamy very delicious gabe
hozen and jacob barikov
you are the winners we will be in
contact and now
what i'm going to do is throw you back
over to titan
we are done this is the end of the
second episode
there are four episodes left there are
chances to win every episode
tune in with us i want to save you money
and i want to make it so you spend less
money excellent here's titan
boom we are helping you make money
compete in this industry bringing free
education
bringing entertainment and uh
he mr dave burgundy is helping you spend
less of that money so you can go on
vacation and buy houses and make it
happen and
boom my son tyson tyson what's up
what's up man so
dice crazy part crazy part yep
long day right two episodes we got
we we have four more episodes to go
tomorrow wednesday and thursday
and uh two episodes per day
but he gets to just chill and finish off
this part we're going to run it on
camera we're going to show it on youtube
it's going to be great
and uh proud of you man yeah thank you a
lot of you guys know tyson
you know at the beginning didn't want to
work at the shop
no no but i'm running five axis parts
five acts as far as 14 years in
teaching the trade to all the people out
there if you guys want to learn lathe
you want to learn the rocket tyson is
the teacher on that and uh there's kids
all over the world machinists all over
the world they love this guy i love this
guy nicest guy
ever and really proud of you today
thanks you killed him man
thank you so tomorrow join us for
episode three
i love you guys we love the trade and
boom
we are out